Are you ready for two jam-packed albums
full of your favorite microscopic hits?
Journey to the Microcosmos: The Soundtrack
volumes one and two make it possible for you
to live every day like you're in the microcosmos.
This 21 song collection is available
exclusively through the Project for Awesome
and features such hits as Aggro by Andrew Huang
Night Ocean by Andrew Huang and old
favorites like Bumbling by Andrew Huang
and Andrew Huang's Comfy Wonder
This all new collection features 21 memorable
hits on two digital albums for only thirteen dollars.
All your favorite hits are right here right now
on this never before available collection.
To order go to the address on your screen. This
collection is not sold in stores and is only
available until February 16th so don't wait! Go to
the address on your screen now to get Journey to
the Microcosmos Volumes one and two for only thirteen dollars!
That's two albums, 21 hits, for just 13 dollars! Order today!